if hell were a place on earth this is
what it might look like the flames
destroyed what two world wars did not
ravaging over 800 years of history as
the spire of not freedom fell to the
inferno people in France and around the
world looked on thousands gathered
nearby in Paris many and shocked at the
scale of the blaze French president
Immanuel McCoy came to stand by them
this Cathedral we were able to build it
more than 800 years ago and over the
centuries to make it grow and improve so
I say to you very solemnly this evening
this Cathedral we will rebuild it all
together and this is probably a part of
French destiny a project we will have
for the coming years but I am committed
to it starting tomorrow a national
fundraising campaign will be launched
some 400 firefighters battled to save
the church's main bell towers they also
rushed into the flames to try to salvage
religious relics and priceless artworks
the fire spread extremely quickly on the
roof wooden beams dating from the 12th
century are thought to be to blame later
some measure of good news
firefighters announced the church's core
structure had been saved
their efforts honored by those who
looked on at the unfolding disaster it's
not just Catholics but also believers
and non-believers we share the same
attachment to note Saddam the party
because it's a landmark it's a place of
refuge in French history notes Adam de
poppy it's where we have gathered in joy
and sorrow throughout our history it's
the end of an era the end of a piece of
history and architecture it's incredibly
unfortunate this is something that will
have the world mourning the loss of this
piece of world heritage is weighing on
many well beyond the streets of Paris
[Music]
and let's go right to DWS Barbara Veysel
she was at the scene in Paris Barbara
good morning to you we can see the the
main structure of the cathedral is still
standing as we said there behind you
bring us up to date on the latest
efforts to fully extinguish the flames
around 4 o'clock this morning the head
of the firefighting services in Paris
said the worst is over we have managed
to contain the fire to extinguish the
the worst fire is that we're sort of
raging in the middle of what we see
behind us here where the scaffolding is
that this is where the spire was that
broke down last night as the first piece
of the Cathedral and all around it is
the vast old roof in two tiers off the
Cathedral dating back really to the 13th
century roof beams like seven eight
hundred years old were in there and this
is really what burned down relentlessly
so during the night we could see to a
one o'clock or so we could see flames
really reaching up to the sky bright red
and then slowly slowly it became darker
when the firefighters managed to beat
back the fire now the problem is they're
still throwing water at the walls of the
Cathedral there in order
to cool it down because with such a huge
fire in the old building like this and
the problem is that there might be nest
somewhere that starts reigniting even
after hours even after days it's still
possible so we can also see the tiny
immense are crawling around in the in
the outer support work of the Cathedral
firefighters and structural engineers
trying to assess what will stand up and
what is still in immediate danger yeah
Barbara as you've been speaking we've
been looking at live pictures of that
scaffolding you were mentioning and the
outside structure of the Cathedral what
morgue our authorities learning this
morning about the extent of the damage
the damage of course is extensive the
cathedrals built from sandstone like all
the historic buildings in in Paris and
the the enormous heat of course damages
the stone it sort of bakes the stone and
it makes it friable so nobody knows yet
really what the what the structural
problems that will be arising could be
the inside of course is heavily damaged
and as one knows from when when a
building you know the apartment building
burns the the water can make worse
damage than the fire itself originally
so huge amounts of water have been
pouring into the historic inside of the
church so a lot of the art in their
paintings and and sculptures and other
works that have been collected there
throughout the centuries are lost what
is lost is a large part of the historic
glass everybody knows not for damn knows
that they're those huge rose windows the
big round windows at the entrance side
beautiful old glass dating back to the
13th century that is lost because it
just simply corrected the enormous heat
of this fire so there is extensive
damage some things could be brought out
during the night but this will be a
horrible task in a tremendous task over
years and years to come
to rebuild this and much will be lost
and not be retrievable it is indeed such
a tragedy Barbara what do we know at
this time about the cause of this fire
the cause of the fire is supposedly
negligence it's an accident as horrible
as that sounds there were works going on
as we see from the scaffolding there
they were working craftsmen were working
in in this roof in this ancient roof
around this spire and obviously
something happened there maybe an
electrical fault
made through some maybe through some
welding works or other things you know
just some sparks sort of struck these
old old beams and they are of causes dry
as tinder and they slowly took fire I
mean two to four oak beams to burn it
takes a while but then the workmen
started they stopped work at five
o'clock yesterday afternoon and the fire
started around seven o clock so it took
for it it took two hours for it to take
hold and so the the prosecutor of Paris
has opened an investigation but they
think it was negligence and it was after
all an accident and it will be
impossible maybe not ever possible to to
exactly figure out what caused it you
know Barbara we've seen such an
outpouring of grief
especially from Parisians and it's safe
to say Notre Dame really is a part of
the city's soul tell us more what about
what people there have been saying to
you people are just said I mean last
night people were standing on the
bridges to the east on Louie where you
have a view all the the rest of the
perimeter of the cathedral was blocked
off by police of course well because
firefighters were going back and forth
and just for security reasons but people
were standing on the bridges and
watching the spectacle but not in the
way that there was sort of like gopping
at it a sensation of it was very quiet
hardly anybody spoke some people were
singing religious hymns and it was you
know some people were sort of making the
Catholic Cross sign and and it was very
everybody even people who said they're
not close to the church said that this
strikes at our hearts because this is a
symbol for Paris and the symbol for the
French nation going back and the
stability and the longevity of the
French nation going back to middle
ages this is really the old heart of
Paris so people are very touched and
there is a general sense of great
sadness you also seen some reactions
from from church leaders and political
leaders let's listen now to some of
those responses I can say this when it's
a monument you love and a monument you
live in which you celebrate which
represents so much in our history it's
really sad and I'm asking God why it's
what we've got some calls from all over
the world because it's a tragedy for the
whole world I've said it before but of
course not true DOM is the entire
history of Paris not true DOM is really
the symbol here of who we are you see
it's a part of our culture it's a part
of our lives that's a truly great
Cathedral and I've been there and I've
seen it and there's no Cathedral I think
I could say this probably no Cathedral
in the world like it it's a tar it's a
terrible scene all right though some of
the reactions there from political and
at church leaders and let's talk more
about this with DW news editor and a
French journalist in Manoa shah's who
joins us here in our studio good morning
to you as well you know we heard some
reaction there from the mayor of Paris
tell us more about what was so special
about the structure of Notre Dame itself
the the wood frame and also the spire
structure of Notre Dame was actually the
original structure so that means it was
850 years old and it survived the French
Revolution it survived various hazards
it's a survived world war one world war
two and that was what was so particular
and so miracles about not hadam is that
it was a building that has that had
managed to remain intact throughout the
centuries and that had managed to remain
untouched through so many historical
events and that made it very special
also it lies at the very heart of Paris
and the first Parisians were actually
buried in the crypt of not rodham so it
made it a very
place for Parisians and for French
people in general what makes it still
such a symbol of French heritage and
history as you were saying and also what
does it mean for Europe well actually
what makes it so special is that no
matter whether you you're a believer or
not no matter what's your faith it is a
place where French people identify with
French culture it is our civilization
and it's also of course it's a Christian
civilization but any French person
identifies with the capital city and
with its monuments such as the Eiffel
Tower the Louvre and of course not Adam
and Angela Merkel the German Chancellor
said yesterday that it was a symbol of
European culture that was disappearing
in the flames and that's exactly how it
is felt it it feels like it's much
bigger than only a French cultural
heritage building yeah that's a
sentiment we've seen over and over again
on Twitter it's a collective symbol of
our civilization of our heritage we just
were seeing some live pictures there
again this morning let's bring Barbara
Basel who's in Paris back into the
discussion Barbara you know plans are
now as we heard from the French
president Amano McCone to rebuild notre
dam is there any sense at this point how
long or how expensive that undertaking
could be it will take very very long
many many years because this is very
difficult and detailed work you're going
to need all the artisans that France
still have and even has an even draft
some from in from other countries
because the whole roof structure it
which is huge this is 60 meters high and
it is more than a hundred meters long
will have to be rebuilt and the whole
interior renovated and then the
structural damage that has been done to
what we can still see standing up there
hasn't yet it hasn't been assessed yet
that is going to take days and weeks so
this is not a question of money and the
first big donation has come in by enoki
know one of the French entrepreneurs and
billionaires who started out was a
hundred million last night and the
public fundraising has been put up
the tragedy here really is that the
French state has neglected not to dam as
many others sort of parts of it the
cultural friend the French cultural
heritage for years it was just a bit
patching here a bit patching there a few
millions here and there so it was really
always underfunded it was never really
thoroughly renovated in the sense that
it would be made safe for the future and
so now this really seems like some awful
revenge for decades-long neglect on the
side of French government's this is not
Emmanuel macron Schwab this is
governments before him that have really
not so to put up the money for this and
now he will have to find hundreds of
millions maybe more than a billion to
rebuild this precious building and in
the end it will never be what it was
because you cannot bring back the
special sense of the age of this 7th of
this place of the building and the this
special sentiment it used to carry em
anyway I want to ask you about that
sentiment we just heard from Barbara
there this the sense that notre dumb and
many cultural heritage symbols that in
France have been neglected by the French
government if there was a headline from
two years ago I remember seeing an
international press saying Nostradamus
crumbling who will pay for it tell us
about the repairs that had been going on
and whether enough had been done to
preserve this very important icon well
first I think we should go back in time
a little bit because friend France is a
secure state where so there's no state
religion and religious buildings are
owned by the state or local authorities
only if they were nationalized prior to
the French Revolution and that means
that we have in France 44,000 cultural
heritage monuments and the state has to
take care of half of it this represents
billions of euros which the state alone
cannot take care of so that so the
renovation restoration works would also
depend on private funds and that's one
of the problems now when it comes to
notre damn it is such a landmark in
Paris of course the authorities had
injured invested
millions of euros in in a renovation
work started in July 2018 and this
renovation worked work should have
lasted 20 years and would have cost in
millions of euros but now due to that
neglect due to that state of negligence
and also due to that fire it will cost
much more and for who knows how many
years and just like Barbara was saying
we will never recover the Rose windows
there are also paintings in valuable
paintings in valuables cultures that
have been damaged not only by the flames
but also by the water atone by the
firefighters so it's a whole it's a huge
loss for a cultural heritage not only
French cultural heritage but worldwide
cultural Haiti and that might indeed be
the price to pay for as you were both
saying you and Barbara neglect over
years by the government but also from
private funds Barbara coming back to you
now you know officials including
President microRNA been thanking the
firefighters who were on the scene all
night last night for their courage is
there any assessment at this point of
how authorities responded to this fire
yeah there seems to be a big problem
there because last night we heard that
it took too long much too long maybe up
to 45 minutes - for a larger number of
firefighters to appear at the scene
because the fire broke out shortly
before 7 o'clock and we talked to some
inhabitants here who are working along
the yield the isle asain islands and one
man told us that he said I saw the shine
of the fire around the spire quite early
on and then there was just a single fire
engine arriving there and now this is a
huge building they normally can't reach
so cranes had to be brought in and for
water to be in the throne at the
Cathedral there was a firefighting boat
on the Thames on the river below as here
there was just throwing huge wads of
water but that was like much later
forces couldn't be mobilized quickly
enough to really contain the fire in its
beginning stages and that was why the
spire collapsed so early and this is why
the whole roof
burned like like like a huge flaming
it's reaching up to the sky red to trill
yeah maybe like until midnight Mall as
so for around five hours so the
questions will be put to the mayor of
Paris I need a logo whether there was an
emergency plan whether it could not be
enacted what happened why was the
response too slow why did it take for
too long to get enough firefighters on
the scene so this morning we still we
see some of them sort of crawling around
carefully on the outer supports of the
buildings here building here behind us
trying to assess what the damage is is
structurally and and they still need to
sort of keep up throwing water at the
building because it can take days for it
to be really quiet and the danger to be
over no matter why you you have been
looking into that as well the questions
being raised about the response time
tell us what you've seen well we got a
little bit more clarity this morning as
to some figures for example we know now
that there were several hundred
firefighters on site around 400 of them
were there a hundred of them were
actually devoted to salvaging artwork
they they came into the Cathedral and
they managed to save a couple of well
most of the treasure treasure chests for
example that was saved they we also
found out that they barely had time to
retreat before the spire collapsed so we
avoided we nearly avoided a tragedy
another tragedy a human tragedy well so
part of my personal feeling when it
happened it those images of the spire
collapsing for some weird reason I
couldn't explain to myself why it
reminded me of 9/11 because I thought
9/11 was a human tragedy and here we
have a cultural tragedy but in the one
case in New York it was thousands of
people disappearing and dying tragically
and here it's a thousand years of
history which is also disappearing and
yet I was really shocked of when when
this all happened yesterday and when
Dave and unfolded really a lot of people
talking about that at that moment in
particular when the spire
well I want to thank you both our
correspondents covering the story for us
this morning a man wash ace here with us
here in studio and Barbara Veysel in
Paris we'll be coming back to you a
little bit later